account your github id and even twitter
so
let me take a brief moment so that the
participants can sign up on the portal
once you have signed up on the portal
please put a yes so that i can
take you through the various features of
the portal
so i'll be waiting for your response
plea please put a yes and if you're
facing any technical issues please put
that in the chat and our team will be
happy to resolve the queries
all right i've got one yes
i'm expecting more yeses
[Music]
all right i've got three s's so
now i'm going to log in since i already
have an account on the portal
so once you sign in this is the
the you you will be landing on the
courses tab so here you'll have the
opportunity to browse through various
courses and example projects that you
can take a look at so since most of you
will be interested in the genomics i'm
going to type genomics
and you will be able to see the diverse
range of topics from quit 19 to ebola
virus that you can take a look at and if
you wish to gain your concepts in
genomics straight first then you can go
through the courses
before that click on the tab that says
welcome back with your email id here is
where you will be able to update your
account so how do you go about doing
that click on the tab that says profile
and here you'll be able to edit your bio
so here i've mentioned my educational
background and my research interest and
i've linked my linkedin account and my
op id so under the activity tab the
mentor and the community manager will be
able to track your progress under the
courses tab you'll be able to view the
present courses that you're taking
and
the projects will uh show the if you
have completed any projects uh under any
pro under any programs and here it shows
the programs that you've entered
so with that and how i'd like to pass on
the stage to dr raghav to begin with
today's webinar over to you doctor
thank you very much and let me find ways
to share my screen
yeah please confirm you can see my
stream and also you can hear me clear
yes yes both are working fine thank you
okay perfect thank you very much so
welcome
to uh the orientation or webinar of
genomics data analysis
let me set it up yeah today we will be
having a
an introduction to what this program has
to offer to us and we will also
have um
a good introduction to different
resources in omixlogic platform and also
the associated how about bioinfo
platform uh with which what we can do
with genomic data analysis what we can
learn and we will quickly go through
couple of demonstration uh that will
help us to annotate
let's say for example um very well known
cancer
driver gene one of the very well known
cancer triggers okay
so
we already spoke about that we will
start with what is genomics data how is
it organized and how is it analyzed and
how is it integrated to be such a
powerful resource in the hands of
researchers like you in the hands of
clinicians and also in the hands of
entrepreneurs that are
reading the code of dna to battle cancer
to fight infectious diseases and even
sometimes to an accent to solve crimes
so let's start by reviewing the
fundamentals of genomics genomics is all
about dna so let's review what is this
dna code what do we already know about
it and what kind of answers can we find
there and how can we analyze huge
sequences of nucleotides stored in the
dna and how do we make sense of that
right
just pretend to be a book just like a
book a dna code is organized letters
that form sentences
and sentences could form paragraphs and
paragraphs are organized into chapters
and knowing how to read this code can
actually help us decipher the full story
about who we are
and
we can look into our history we can
understand how we are connected to other
living things that are
living around us
so dna is short for deoxyribose nucleic
acid it is a long molecule composed of
two chains of coil that go around each
other to form a double helix this
carries genetic instructions for
development for the function growth and
reproduction of all known life right
this these uh all known life forms
include multi and single cellular
organisms as well as many bacteria and
even some viruses
yeah
so human genome for example has three
billion base pairs in one
yeah in one chromosome
okay
so a dna code contains directions or it
contains recipes for life life is the
condition how can it be defined it can
be defined that it is a condition that
distinguishes animals and plants uh from
inorganic matter that
this condition could include the
capacity for growth it could into
reproduction it could include functional
activity it could also include continual
change preceding depth
so this instruction for life
include life of a single cell and an
organism like us humans which contain
over 37 trillion cells among us right
each cell contains the same dna which is
stored tightly around the nuclei inside
a nucleus
when the cells divide as they do when a
new organism is formed or when a new
cell has to be generated
we see how this dna is organized so we
get a hint about this organization of
this dna into chromatins and other forms
the nucleus is opened up and inside we
discovered these tightly packed strings
that can be visible under uh low power
microscope posture
so
it is we already saw that it could be
tightly packed into 23 pairs of
chromosomes right one of the chromosomes
come from my from our mother and the
others come from other come from our
father right the unique structures of
these chromosomes will keep the dna
tightly wrapped around the spool like
proteins called histones without such
packaging these dna molecules would be
too long to fit inside the cell for
example if all of the dna molecules
inside a single human cell were to be
unbound from their histones and placed
end to end they would stretch up to six
feet
the largest chromosome which is
chromosome 1 contains about 8 000 genes
and while for
to compare the smallest chromosome
chromosome 21 contains only about 300
genes
and once the cell division is complete
the information on the cell function
stored inside the dna helps the new cell
know what to do to continue the function
it will work on for the rest of its life
and preserve the dna to pass it on to
the next cell that it will form when it
divides and in the meantime the dna
contains instruction for various
functions a cell must perform to grow
and maintain this life function itself
so therefore the dna code contains both
actively needed recipes and all kinds of
other instructions that need to be
stored but not necessarily used all the
time so together all of the specific
code in a chromosome can be termed as a
genotype
yeah my
animation stopped working suddenly so
the product of this code and how it
interacts with the environment is what
we call as phenotype a phenotype can
describe a single cell a tissue an organ
or the whole organism the phenotype of
an organism might include height size
activity while the phenotype of a cell
might include its specific function
says
size and sometimes its morphology
so molecularly
at the molecular level
the dna is made up of nucleotides and
nucleotides chemical
position
what suddenly happened
uh yes sir i guess you need to share
your screen once more yeah
yeah can you see it
yes
okay we were discussing about the
molecular structure of the dna so dna at
its molecular level is made up of
nucleotides and one nucleotide is
actually made up of a sugar called drc
ribose and
nitrogen containing base and a phosphate
group the nucleotides are joined to one
another in a chain by covalent bonds
that form between the sugar molecule of
one nucleotide and the phosphate of the
next resulting in alternating sugar
phosphate back
each strand of dna molecule contains a
sequence of bases that is complementary
to the bases in the opposite strand
the pairing between these complementary
bases gives rise to the characteristics
double helix shape of the dna in this
structure a is bound to t
and g is bound to c
so to understand how dna works and to
read its sequence
a special project was aimed at decoding
dna that was launched like
in 1990
this
13-year long project which was initiated
in 1990 focused on determining the dna
sequence of the entire human genome
scientists set out to determine the dna
sequence and the location of estimated
100 000 human g
code estimated at the time of this
discovery
many at the time believed that once we
had such sequence we would quickly be
able to determine where all the genes
were and the process of reading dna
sequences and piecing together late this
process of reading these dna sequences
and piecing together laid the foundation
of what we know known as genomics
so but simply reading the code and
annotating it became much longer process
than the human genome project itself
today there are several competing human
gene databases with many thousands of
differences among them and although the
number of protein coding genes had
gradually converge the number of other
gene types are exploding the latest
count had found over 21 000 genes since
the human genome
project was complete
so uh from the estimate of 100 000 at
the beginning of the human genome
project now everybody agrees that there
are around 21 000 genes in the
protein coding genes that are found in
our
human body but
something supposed to be noted that
these protein coding genes form only one
to two percentage of the entire genome
so much more information about how these
protein coding genes are regulated and
how how these protein coding genes are
translated into proteins are encoded in
the other 98 percentage of the
gene
so this dna is stored inside the nucleus
as organized into chromosome and
specific regions right some of the
easiest regions to read and evaluate are
called these protein coding genes that
we just discussed so the protein coding
genes are nothing but the sequences that
are used to produce proteins
and how are they produced this is
defined or this is described in the
central dogma of molecular biology which
describes a two-step process
transcription and translation by which
the information in the gene flows into
the protein via an rna right
in each step of this transformation we
see how the dna code is used
first transcribing the source code into
a working repository of rna where some
of this code is modified and then it is
released to produce a protein
my animation is actually running slow so
this process is facilitated by several
key proteins one of which is called dna
polymerases that attaches itself to dna
as it unzips the double helix and
replicates the dna to form a single
strand adding complementary bases and
creating a second copy this copied code
can then be used in another cell but
it's important to make such a
replication go
it is important to make sure that this
process goes without any mistakes so a
lot of cells instrumentation are
designed to prevent such mistakes while
carrying out these processes
each gene is a recipe for specific
protein so it encodes instruction from
this
from which a protein can be made right
the proteins are actually product of
amino acids which are encoded by
trinucleotide codons that are stored on
the dna so a codon is actually a
sequence of three nucleotides that
corresponds to a specific amino acid or
a stop signal which will stop the
production of this specific protein
once the right place on the dna is
copied over it is prepared by
translating
this into a
it is prepared for translation
by forming a messenger rna which is
exported from the nucleus into the
cytosol where this messenger rna is
actually translated into protein
again
this is running stuff okay so
in human cells alone genes vary in size
from few hundred dna bases to more than
two million bases for example
the keratin associated protein gene like
kr tap is the smallest gene that we have
characterized until now it is only 447
meter types long whereas
cnt and ap2 gene for example has over 2
million nucleotides the number of genes
also vary between various organisms for
example influenza virus has only 11
genes while the grape genome has over 30
000 genes
genes are not just a
simple organization of sequences of
nucleotides in fact they have upstream
and downstream regulatory sequences that
controls the transcription of these
genes inside the gene sequence itself
there are codons and there are introns
that undergo splicing before a gene is
translated into protein the
extraordinary length of some of these
genes is enabled by the presence of
introns which as a substrate for
which acts as a substrate for insertion
and deletion of several transposable
elements this also provides a mechanism
for the generation of diversity through
alternative combinations of these exons
which is also known as splice forms
so the translation in the cell is done
by the ribosome which can read the mrna
sequence and assemble a
protein that will fold into a functional
structure
then
yeah
when we want to understand the function
of a particular protein we typically
combine the information about its
chromosome position
its coding sequences its regulatory
region the structure of the protein as
well as the functional features of the
protein through various experimental
validation and through various
bioinformatics comparative analysis
approaches
so before going into uh
how this
dna could be
analyzed and how they could be
understood
i want to stop here and ask if you have
any queries or questions until now
if you don't have any questions please
let me continue and if you have
questions please put it in the chat box
i am following the chat box so we will
address your questions as we go back so
that is a short introduction about the
dna its organization genes and how they
form basic
fundamental element and functional
element of any each and every cell now
let's let's see or let's discuss how to
analyze this dna code and what are the
information that we are going to extract
from analyzing this dna code right
so the
we recently crossed the 70-year mark
since the discovery of structure and
function of the dna molecules and it
took something around 50 years from the
time to sequence the first human gene
but soon after that point the technology
developed so much that the availability
of the human genome just exploded
rapidly so by around 2015 1000 genome
project was
was launched and it brought actually
significant number of whole genome
sequences into the research community
and
again it went too fast yeah
we discussed this
so non-coding rnas are also part of the
part of the gene
or genome not
actually genome so they serve specific
function
in regulating which part of our which
which gene are actually uh
translated by how much so now
several important functions of the long
and short non-coding rnas are actually
actively being identified and actually
be discussed and their their
participation and their
role in regulating these genes could
actually serve as a purpose to
understand several disease state of a
cell or several altered state of the sun
so it collectively the omics
aims at
characterization and quantification of
the
different biological molecules
yes we can use several available public
genomics database like ncbi and etc
are
part of that so to know more about how
to use these databases for what kind of
data and what kind of analysis it
the program actually discusses a lot
about that and how we can leverage the
publicly available resources for our own
research so let's continue with that we
were discussing about the omics data in
particular so the omics data
aims at collective characterization and
quantification of the biological
molecules that translate into structure
function and dynamics of an organism
right the omix technologies are used to
explore the roles relationships actions
of various types of molecules that make
up the cell open organisms many type of
these omics data can be generated using
next generation sequencing technology
which is also known as high throughput
sequencing technology the data can show
detailed information about general
genomic variance about
epigenetic variants and about
transcriptomics
expression pattern of genes and isoform
level also so the suffix ohm actually
defines or refers to the various
referred to various field of omics in
molecular biology and bioinformatics
refers to a totality of all analysis of
all of these different or mixed data
types for example the word genome was
actually first coined in germany in the
beginning of around 20th century
the word genomics refers to the totality
of the genome or the studies of
genomes
genomics actually itself is an
interdisciplinary field of biology
focusing on the structure function
evolution
mapping and editing of genomes the
genome of an organism is a complete set
of dna as we discussed and this includes
all of its gene in contrast to very well
known
branch of biology genetics which refers
to the study of individual genes and
their roles in inheritance genomics aims
at a collective characterization and
quantification of an organism's genes
and their relationships and influence on
the
organisms
what happens to the introns after
protein synthesis so sometimes they are
actually discarded right only exons
which are um
which form part of the mrna sequences
are actually exported to this exported
to the cytosol where protein synthesis
takes place introns do not cross the uh
or several known introns right 99
percentage of the introns do not cross
the uh
boundary or um
nucleus nuclear membrane as such
so what do we do by what do we mean by
studying genomics right as a result of
lot of genomics efforts we can now
detect differences which can be harmless
or we can detect differences which can
lead to serious issues when a genius
purpose the whole study of genomics is
centered or focused on identifying
specific differences what we term as
variance or mutation or polymorphism
which we will discuss in further slides
in the available dna sequence right
these can actually occur as a result of
copying the dna source too many times or
as a result of various stresses that can
interfere with the
regulatory mechanisms or it can
happen in several different random ways
also right and once such variation or
such
mistakes or mutation occurs the end
result can be devastating for the
organism or the cell in particular for
example here one single nucleotide
change results in an amino acid change
that completely changes the shape of
this red blood cells which leads to uh a
very popularly characterized
condition called sickle cell anemia
so to understand how genomics is used
first we have to understand the analysis
approaches to dna codes specifically
what we can identify how we can identify
these changes and how we can
characterize them and how we can
interpret their significant significance
and this we spoke about
so
there are several mutations as we spoke
about right there are several changes to
the dna code and what are these changes
and how can they be characterized and
categorized
we can refer to some of the mutations or
changes as substitution mutation a
substitution mutation can cause several
consequences to the dna code but it
implies a minimal change that only leads
to a single nucleotide change
whenever a
a change in their nucleotide or change
in their copied in a dna sequence
results in a change in one nucleotide
level change at one meter at a level
that is termed as substitution mutation
and while an insertion mutation can be
defined as an insertion of a new
nucleotide
to the copied dna sequence compared to
the
template dna sequence this insertion
changes the number of dna bases in the
gene by adding one or more pieces of dna
as a result
the protein made by the gene may not
function properly because it now encodes
completely new set of amino acid
sequences
and deletion
mutation actually refers to removal of
one or more
number of nucleotide base in the copied
dna sequence compared to the template
dna sequence and this deletion actually
changes number of dna bases by removing
a piece of dna small deletions may
remove one or large deletions may remove
uh an entire gene or several neighboring
genes this will definitely alter the
function of the resulting protein as we
discussed with the insertion also and
as the
deletion mutation may result in the uh
and result in the complete change of the
encoded protein sequence which will now
uh change in this change at the
structural level and also the functional
lab
so and while there are also other
variations that are possible like gene
duplication or duplication of regions
that are abnormally copied one or more
times the type of mutation
yeah this type of mutation may also
alter the function of the resulting
protein every type of mutation that we
are actually dealing with has to end up
or
are interesting only when it ends up at
the level of
at the level of functional implications
to the protein that it encodes and point
mutations are nothing but when all these
variances or changes occurs at one
nucleotide level when the sub
substitution is always point mutation
and when the insertion occurs at one
single mutation level a single
nucleotide level and deletion occurs at
single nucleotide level and those are
all termed as point mutations as the
change occurs in single point of the
genomic position
so
there are
two basic
terminologies that we need to be very
clear about
we term
some some of the changes as genetic
variation and certain other changes as
genetic mutation a specific type of
variation that leads to harmful results
for example a change in function that is
harmful
are termed as mutation for example if
you see this graphic we have the wild
type
icon or pikachu here and while
there could be several variation for the
genomes that
compared to the wild type
variant of this pikachu and these
variation will produce noticeable change
in the phenotype or morphology of the
organism like blue eyes or here but like
a lack of the fur or lack of
pigmentation but these and also addition
of new features but these are not
supposedly dangerous or supposedly
harmful to the organism itself when the
variation that we are studying are not
generally harmful to the organism
themselves then they are
these changes are termed as genetic
variation but while when this variation
results in harmful changes are results
in loss of function or complete
alteration of function that leads to
abnormalities in the organism themselves
then they are termed as pathogenic
mutation so we refer to mutations
and they are always annotated or they
are always associated with harmful end
result and variation they are always
associated with unknown consequences or
consequences that are
generally accepted to be less harmful or
no
known harmful effects identified for
those genetic variations of genomic
so when these genomic variants are often
discussed we use both mutation and
variance and also sometimes polymorphism
is also used
several times by convention human
genetic research any genomic variant
with the population frequency of less
than one percentage is called as
mutation and whereas uh the variant with
the population frequency of more than
one percentage is called as quality
for example
upon observing around yeah um
if i'm studying a sample of more than
one percentage of the population of the
people or ethnicity that i want to study
about and if and all the variants that i
am observing in more than one percentage
of those
of those sample sizes right of those
population sizes uh i have to name them
or i have to turn them as polymorphism
and less than one percentage of
of variance at the population level not
at the sample level at the population
level should be termed only as variance
or mutation depending upon their
depending upon their
pathogenicity right let's name it right
this distinction actually is such based
on population frequency rather than the
sample frequency as we actually
discussed right however as a rule a rare
mutation tend to have functional impact
that deviates from wild type while um
in contrast polymorphisms generally
connote two less functionally deviant
genomic variants right
generally when we refer to something as
a single nucleotide polymorphism we
refer to
only those changes are mainly to those
changes that are less harmful or that
are known to harbor the changes of the
phenotypic level that are not harmful to
the races for example to
discuss an example the very well-known
blue eyes of caucasians in europe and
also some some of them in america is a
result of single nuclear set of single
nucleotide polymorphisms in the gene
that corresponds to pigmentation in our
um eye level right advice for the eyes
and while
mutations
however rare they could be
they can result in some serious
some serious effects a good example of
such a mutation that causes serious
changes in the phenotypical level is is
at the fgfs gene that causes extremely
long hair to be uh to grow what eyebrows
and eyelashes to to a certain level that
it um that it
that it affects the um
picture a quality of life of the person
or people involved
so we we spoke about different types of
variants and mutations at the level of
nucleotides right now we can actually
characterize the same new
variance and sorry variance and
mutations at the level of
amino acid
amino acid
residue that the
trinucleotide codon actually encodes for
example we can have a missense mutation
which
which refers to change in one dna base
pair that results in substitution of one
amino acid for another in the protein
made by this specific gene for example
in this case uh one change in the
nucleotide at the nucleotide level
changes this one specific
amino acid from tryptophan to system
this is a mis-sense mutation and some
are actually termed as nonsense mutation
where change in one
nucleotide level prematurely stops the
building up of protein and this results
in a shortened protein that may not
function properly at all right there is
also other kind of
changes like frame shift mutation where
insertion or deletion of dna bases
changes the entire reading frame of the
codon themselves so resulting in a
protein that is completely different
from what it is supposed to be produced
at the wild type level and most often
these proteins are usually
non-functional
so to summarize we can
we can summarize this as genomic
variation can be of several different
types when analyzing genomic data
we are looking to find and characterize
the changes in the dna code and
associate them with the phenotype of the
organisms so some of the acronyms that
we actually discussed and we should
actually remember are s ps and s and is
right and to reiterate s and v are
single nucleotide variant a single
nucleotide change that may or may not be
present in the whole of the population
basically this means any change from the
reference genome found in the given dna
sequence above the level of technical
effect right all the changes that we
find in our sample data that differs
from the reference sequence are curved
or are categorized as single nucleotide
variants
and single nucleotide polymorphism is
when a nucleotide that is known to be
altered in a proportion of population
typically the proportion considered
is approximately at the one percentage
level of the population and there are
also other
other terminologies like copy number
variation when a gene is encoded
multiple copies encoded in multiple
copies and the number of copies varies
between the reference genome and in the
sample that we are analyzing so these
changes as well as the characteristics
of these variants that we are actually
analyzing and identifying are commonly
referred to as the genotype of that
specific organism
so before moving on further if you have
any queries please uh
share it with me
okay there is a general query about
like to do about projects about projects
we will
actually get to know the end of the
session and
yeah and about the genomic databases we
actually discussed so let's move ahead
and see
how is genomics or how supposedly are
these variants and understanding of
these variants are used in real life to
help us understand the impact of the
genomic data let's take a look at
some of the genetically inherited
conditions and diseases such as cancer
mutations in oncogenes oncogenes and
sometimes like infectious diseases and
for which drug resistance is involved
and sometimes like genetic genetically
inherited conditions like sickle cell
anemia and other cases
right
so
most of the data that we are discussing
here or information that discussing here
and several other
examples of how genomics data analysis
are helping us understand this
several implications are actually
available in the omixlogic platform into
several example projects these projects
will actually
address at
address at enzyme function level for
example at the drug metabolism or
understanding somatic mutations for
tumor development or understanding
genetically inherited mutations in the
case of sickle cell anemia and other
genetically inherited diseases or
sometimes understanding the rare
single nucleated variants that are
involved in changes in the
structure and function level of some
critically involved protein and also
some of the variants that are
known to
known to
develop drug resistance in the pathogen
at the pathogen level not at the host
after the host interaction
some of the known pathogens like
mycobacterium tuberculosis and even
sometimes some sas variants are known to
develop drug resistance to very well
known antibiotics and anti
antiviral
drugs that we are actually using so far
so these are all some of the project
examples that we will be dealing
uh progression progression of the
program and you will learn a lot about
how the data or what kind of what type
of data is analyzed and what is the
analysis process and
how are we actually
using curated set of curated data sets
to
understand this level of genetic
variance and its association with the
disease time
so for example to give you an example
upon
a patient may be requested to
go for
dna sequencing
for to help with the prognosis and
diagnosis of the disease so upon
receiving this sequencing results for
any sick patient the first question
we usually ask or the first question is
that is usually
addressed is what are the genes that are
affected so this is not a very simple
question to ask while genomics is
already used for
currently being used for extensively
using diagnostics
and
diagnostics levels in clinical care many
of these dna variants are still being
discovered and still being annotated and
rigorously analyzed by by the
researchers and by
different
scientific groups and entrepreneurs all
over the world
so for example in the association of
cancer the dna variation can help
determine the genetic risk associated
with oncogenes right but most often
oncologists look for somatic mutation in
tumor suppressor genes or in onco genes
or dna repair genes which are all very
well known to be associated with the
tumor progression so since cancer often
since cancer most often occurs with the
age many researchers see or often notice
this accumulation of somatic mutation in
key genomic regions as a combination of
driver
mutation which can be associated to the
progression of tumor and
passenger mutation which can be
associated with the
the result of this tumor progression
in the genome at the genomic level right
this can actually help
help us diagnose the cancer early on it
can actually help us evaluate the risk
of the cancer severity it can actually
help us
look for appropriate treatment to slow
down this
cancer progression and help us
deal with this incurable metastatic
cancer
so one particular gene
of interest is the tumor protein
p53 or tp53 this encodes for a protein
that is responsible for tumor
suppression generally it is present in
all the cells it is implicated in many
cancer and it helps prevent tumor growth
through the process called apoptosis
some or several mutation in these genes
can lead to loss of function and
ultimately promoting tumor genesis by
not controlling the replication of the
cells that
harbors abnormal growth with damaged dna
so this is one of the very well known
gene that is associated with the tumor
progression and that we will also
discuss in uh in a short while
other diseases like cystic fibrosis can
also be linked to individual
genes like cftr gene which can affect
the function of the channel that is
responsible for clearing mucus from
this is this is an example of uh
diseases that is caused at the uh caused
by genetically inherited mutation right
these mutations are inherited uh
genetically and
and
identifying such variants and such
mutations can actually help in dealing
with
some really deadly diseases like cystic
fibrosis in this level for example um
people or person that is harboring this
specific variant or mutation to cftrg
can be
suggested to some
suggested to um
treatment options that targets this
specific channel to open up for clearing
the mucus level at the
for the patients who are suffering from
cystic fibrosis
so and in generally also some more
significant dna variation
[Music]
where
the variation is now focused on not on
not at the single nucleotide variant
level or collection of mutation level it
is now focused on abnormal number of
copies that is present in one specific
chrom
present for one specific gene in
specific chromosome
4. so in this case it
we are actually dealing with huntington
disease
where the httg which is associated with
the huntington's disease encodes a large
num large protein huntingtin protein and
the aberration that is caused is the
multiple insertion and deletions of
multiple insertions and deletions are
there at this specific nucleotide level
which results in abnormally long
huntingtin protein and hence the
huntington disease actually
results in this one right
several of this information is actually
available to us due to the efforts of
researchers and the private uh and the
publicly funded
consortium which publishes studies on
several individuals with these diseases
and and in this specific case the
huntington's consortium actually
published a study of over 1000
individuals with early and late onset of
this disease and um
by
by actually applying targeted sequencing
and as well as whole genome sequencing
and this treasure flow of data is
actually used by multiple way
used at multiple levels to understand
the disease and in generally understand
the level of dna aberration and their
involvement in
the pathogenic effects of this dna
variation
right
so as i mentioned
these
changes in the dna or changes in the
genomics level and their
characterization should not stop at the
human level
where we are mostly dealing with
responses to these
response sometimes we could be dealing
with responses to externally activated
stress factors like infection that
are
causes due to
external factors like
stimulus due to pollution and other
criteria or abnormal indigestion and
several other
situations so in this specific case for
infectious diseases we we can actually
use the same approach of studying
variants but not in the organism not at
the human level where
microbacterium tuberculosis
actually causes severe diseases right
we can study the genomic sequence of the
pathogen and understand
what these variations in the pathogens
genome actually refers to in
in terms of
understanding the characteristics of the
pathogen for increased virulence or
increased resistance to specific drugs
right
so to give you some sort of
relation and understanding right in in
20th century hello tuberculosis
was the leading cause of death in united
states only right and and today most of
the cases are cured with specific or
special regimen of antibiotic treatment
that can stretch over several months
however recently we have come to know
that this bacteria has become more and
more resistant to
several or single type of antibiotics so
it turns out that the resistance or this
resistance is a result of one or
multiple mutations in specific genes are
sometimes in the promoter that are
preceding these genes
understanding which gene and which at
what position these variants
actually are characterized and
categorized to
different drug resistance level which
will actually help us
design
a very efficient ways and efficient
antibiotics and develop new drugs to
address the surge of
multi-drug-resistant tuberculosis
infections and there is also
another level of this drug resistance
which is called as extensively
drug-resistant tuberculosis which simply
is drug resistant to any type of
antibiotic and any type of preventive
measures so such
resistance levels of pathogen the
resistant pathogens are actually
arising from the changes or random
changes in the
at the dna level or of the genomic level
which suddenly could be beneficial to
the pathogen
and very well known case of this is in
the viral genome and here we have an
example of ebola virus
where um
changes at the one are changes at one
specific protein or one specific
glycoprotein increase their transmission
and back transmission and
virulence of this ebola virus but we
have we are actually
witnessing the same level of
changes and
variance and variance of concern values
of interest in the source
with tatami that we
that we are currently facing right now
all of these changes at the
genomic level um can actually
result in the changed characteristics of
transmission or virulence for this viral
for these viruses specific virus
specifically and only
some of them could be beneficial to the
virus but most of them could be
detrimental
since virus actually replicates at an
accelerated rate so we have a larger
population of these
of these virus which eventually ends up
ends up with the increased transmission
rate or increased
virulence rate and hence hence the birth
of new and novel and
strains and variants of concerns and
various of interests as we have been
witnessing in the last two years so far
right so before going to how to
practically get this information from
the
sequence of genome or sequence of dna in
the genome so if you have any questions
please again put them in the chat box we
will go through
and
while we actually understood or while we
actually discussed that the technology
which will allow us to generate digital
information from the biological sample
is called next generation sequencing or
high throughput sequencing or ngs this
technology as we know was first
developed during the human genome
project and has evolved tremendously
since then right so many different
sequencing techniques were introduced
over the years i'm not going to go over
them let's quickly go over them so in
short we have short read sequences and
long-range sequences and each of them
short read and long-range sequences have
their own place in understanding the
genomic variance at the dna sequence
level so these different sequencing
techniques actually
why are why is it coming twice i don't
know
okay so um actually will allow
researchers like us to explore genetic
variations like never before done to a
single nucleotide resolution and these
different
techniques will actually help us explore
the genomic variants have different
resolution as we mentioned so this could
be at for example core genome level
where we have uh where is it
at whole genome level
where we have to sequence all of the dna
bases and
since the
amount of
information that is generated is huge
and that involves lot of
resources in terms of money in terms of
time in terms of sample preparation in
terms of library preparation and hence
this is done at an average coverage of
30x which defines the number of times
one specific dna base is being read so
this is an average coverage of 30x
average of 30x to be
sufficient enough to build a map of
whole genome of the sample that we are
interested in and get get it compared to
the reference genome to understand
sequence variation at the whole genome
level we can actually not focus on all
the genome right if we are interested
only on the
transcriptome or gene coding or protein
coding part of the genome we can cut
down considerably on the amount of uh
dna sequences that are dna bases that
are sequenced and hence those and hence
the resources that are used to do
used to
prepare libraries and sequence the
sequence of dna basis at the whole
genome sequences can be
used to focus only on the whole exo
sequencing are
only the protein coding regions of the
genome and
such
such a level of sequencing can be
performed or usually is performed at a
100x coverage level because our aim is
to identify some of the rare variants
that are present in the protein coding
regions of the genome and which will
help us associate this
variance and mutations to
this is typed and we can also actually
focus on
targeted sequencing which will target
specific regions of the gene
and and that will
again reduce the number of our amount of
resources that we need to understand the
genomic sequences but there we have to
have some sort of prior physiological or
biological understanding about that
about the regions that we are going to
talk
so how is this actually done to give you
a preview or to give you a short
introduction right the ngs technology
captures the dna sequences and generates
a digital data using several steps first
the rna or the genomic dna in this case
is extracted from the cells and is then
sheared and is placed in the flows and
inside the flow cell these fragments of
shear dna are amplified using pcr
amplification or bridge pcr
amplification method then these
amplified cdna copies or fragments are
then inserted into the sequencer and the
machine uses a form of image analysis to
capture each and every letter in the
flow cell fragments by analyzing visual
patterns and converting them into the
sequence of letters so typically
next generation sequencing reads are
between
30 base pairs to 300 base burst and they
contain series of these dna bases that
are at gnc
and this is such raw data raw sequencing
data to analyze such raw data many
different tools of genomic data analysis
are used and they include alignment of
reads and
[Music]
these include alignment alignment of
reads
and analysis of relationships between
the sequences and their evolutionary
divergence and the measurements of gene
expressions and relationships between
sequences and structures and
identification of somatic and germline
variants and there are these are
different methods with which we can
analyze this this raw data and the tbio
info server is an example of a platform
or a big data platform that can be used
expertly to perform all types of these
analysis and many others using an
intuitive user friendly interfaces some
of this we are going to have a look
right now so when when this genomics
data analysis is performed it is usually
performed with the fast q files which
are the output of the
next generation sequencer machines right
there are several important steps to be
considered such as preprocessing
mapping
variant calling annotation of variances
and cross processing of these variances
to understand their impact
by relating that to the phenotypical and
biological state of the sample
for each task you can connect the
analysis jobs into a pipeline and each
ones will have various inputs and
outputs sometimes it is just enough to
visualize the first you find alignment
to reference genome to quickly get an
understanding of major variants that are
present in our data but
for most of the time we will we might
want to extend this to identification of
these variants by statistically viable
method so that we can
perform downstream analysis with lot of
confidence and
identify
very well annotated mutations
like mutations that are associated with
the busy state like
mutations that are associated with
some altered phenotypical conditions of
the biology that is already been studied
etcetera
so yeah this is for example the
downstream analysis uh will actually
find a list of mutations a list of
variants and these can be represented
and this can be
displayed in a different multiple
different ways visualize in a multiple
different ways one can form
at the basic level we can annotate this
as what type of mutation that they are
causing at the protein level or we can
annotate this to
what type of diseases that these
variants are associated with so they can
be tabulated recent can give you lot of
information regarding these individual
variants or we can visualize these
variants at the plot like this which is
called as lollipop plot where the length
of the plot will uh directly refer to
the
number of variants that are present in
our
data and we can also visualize their
impact at the amino acid level by
mapping their variance or variation onto
the three-dimensional structure of the
protein that at that this g actually
encodes to and identify whether the
variation that is observed at the
three-dimensional structure of the
protein is concentrated at the
functional part of the protein or
whether it is concentrated at the
structural part of it
so this and several other related data
can be related information and
steps to perform this analysis can be
found in the genomics course which we
will
refer to and use extensively in the
program and
along with several other publicly
several other
example project which uses publicly
available data to perform specific
analysis types for different data to
arrive at a
special biologically implicated
conclusion that we will discuss so if
you have no questions until now i want
to quickly reshare my screen to
to show you how these analysis can be
performed and what we will be able to
learn from these analysis models
and let me find where is mine
is this again this is
so please confirm you can see my screen
and i have now opened course 3 the
genomics course in the omixlogic website
can you see my screen
yes sir it's good
yeah thank you very much so this is the
server tbio info server and those who
have
access to this server can actually
follow along with me or if you want if
you prefer to watch what i am trying to
do and trying to uh give uh get a sense
of what can be done you are
free to do so so
so in the server t bio info platform
under the genomic section we are right
now
discussing extensively about this
mutation variant or analysis of mutation
variant data so if you drop down this
option and there are several demo
projects that are available which will
give you the sense of building up of
this pipeline with all the necessary
steps involved or most of the necessary
steps involved and
it will help you analyze the output file
so that you can say get a sense of what
is being done and what we will get at
the end of this analysis method so let
us take one specific demo pipeline where
we are trying to
understand variants that are specific to
the tp53 gene and this data is a
targeted sequencing data and you will
know what do you mean what i mean by
targeted sequencing data you know why so
anybody who has uh um
credentials to access turbo bio info
platform or are actually will be
will actually get access to this demo
pipeline irrespective of the
subscription level that they are at so
you are free to explore this so let's
start
so while you are starting we have
actually uploaded the all necessary
input files to you so let's
perform the analysis observe that the
next step or next possible steps are
actually highlighted in this specific
pipeline we are actually using only
these steps but while in truth when you
are going to build a pipeline at each
and every step the pipeline is going to
give you all possible route that you can
take and you have to choose depending
upon the type of analysis that you want
to do and the type of question that you
are asking in this specific
pipeline i am just happy visualizing the
variant that i have uh oh no sorry for
not i am
in addition to visualizing the mapping
of
q files or of the reads onto the
reference zero i also want to identify
the variants that are present in my data
so i include a variant calling algorithm
or pipeline into this
step into this pipeline and i'm ending
the date ending the
analysis pipeline right now upon
pressing n you get access to all the
output files you are free to download
this long or large vcf file and check
what this vcf file generally will look
like right while the mapping stats table
will tell you how good your
mapping of
the samples that you sequence to the
reference
and all of this information are
condensed into this genome visualization
option
which you can visualize
intuitively so when you open this this
actually loads up the mapping table or
mapping stats table and the first key
statistics that you want to
convert to or you want to focus on is
the overall alignment rate when you see
an overall alignment rate of over 90
percentage you are generally happy with
the status or with the quality of your
sample
so i see that the alignment is excellent
for my sample so i no longer need this
information i am going to
close this over to available real estate
right okay so i have several of the
tracks that is available in this
visualization platform what do i want to
visualize i first want to see the frame
of reference that is reference sequence
and so i enable that and i also want to
see the annotation of this reference
sequence are all the genes that are
that can be named in this reference
sequence so i am going to enable the gtf
or gff5 that is associated with the
reference
and that is given here and these are all
the reads that i have you can actually
enable them to
visualize their alignment here and but
first i want to see the result of my
variant calling pipeline by enabling the
vcf file out
and i want to see
for one of the sample due to time and
due to memory uh constraints i will just
enable only one sample here so that i
can visualize that i like it
when all of this is done and for this
specific data you will not visualize
anything because the nature of the data
as i mentioned the data the sample we
have taken is targeted sequencing effort
and that targets only tp53 gene so when
we type tp53 we can go to tp53 once you
are in tp53 it's going to load up all
the results and all the analysis that we
have
done so far so it says zoom into c
sequences and these are all the reads
that are mapped on to this specific
portion of the sequences and this is
these are all the variants that we have
identified from our sample compared to
the reference sequences here and the gta
file is still loaded and this is the
organization of the pp53 gene so let me
take
this specific portion right you can
select like this
and that's going to zoom into this
region
so i can make some rearrangement by not
showing translation and pull this up
and i can see that this will correspond
to the the height of this peak will
correspond to the alignment of this read
on to this specific region and i can see
variance at several places let's see
some
here exactly this point right so if you
click on this one specific variant it
tells that this is a single nucleotide
variant and this level where the c is
actually
converted or changed to t and that
corresponds to this specific variant
where
you can see that um
if you can read what's inside that
specific
box which says on which corresponds to
this red
line or red bar
on the red bars the height of the bar
signifies to the alignment score or
confidence of this alignment to this
at this specific position and
we have uh variant characteristics of
this specific or this particular
position the position is
like
seven million six hundred centipede
three hundred and twenty six and uh we
have a reference um
uh we have uh an altered sequence here
where the reference is altered to t at
ninety nine percentage of the positions
you can see there and
and
and for for understanding what is the
reference we can refer to the
point mutation or
single nucleated variant at the vcf
visualization than the reference
sequences reference nucleated basis
cytosine and now it is actually mutated
or
converted into time so additional
information about this variant is
actually found on the right side panel
of this specific visualization so this
is just one example of how to visualize
your variant and their alignment
strength this is again just only one
specific for example you can take this
feature details one uh specific track if
you enable all of the track then you
will be able to understand or you will
be able to
relate to how many of my sample harbor
this specific variant and whether that
is
valid or not for example if you go
little bit on to the left or right you
will find
not so strong bar right this has a very
tall bar and not so strong bar that
means for example this specific variant
that means the reference sequence has 86
percentage of the reference nucleotide
present in our sample and only remaining
13 or 14 percentage is actually
distributed to several different other
variants that we generally see here so
this is how you can visualize the
visualize your pipeline results and i
also wanted to show you
available resources to perform some
analysis in r to clinically
annotate your results i'm not going to
go over them or i'm not going to
demonstrate to them because of
not much time so it's available here
so what you can do is you can take this
vcf file that is the output that that
this pipeline gives you an output right
this this vcf file you can take this and
load in an environment like r
where you can read each and every one of
these
variants and process them and store them
separately
and you clinically available
variants that are characterized in the
clinvar database and this database not
only lists all the variants that are
available for that specific gene or
specific in in fact for all of the
genome and
it actually it also annotates them as
at the clinical significance level like
this being
benign or this variant being
unannotated or this varied being
likely pathogenic or this very being
clinically pathetic so we can go through
several steps of selecting only
clinically pathogenic variants and
comparing that with the variance that we
have identified for our sample and in
this specific case we can actually
identify
six uh
six uh specific variant and one of them
being that we discussed so far and where
the c is changed to t i think that is
this is a this is the same variant
and this variant is actually
characterized as lightly benign in the
clean bar database and we have several
other variants that are also
characterized as binay and when you do
this analysis for for example this is a
curated data and hence the only variance
or only significance that we could
identify is likely benign or benign and
when you do this analysis to uh for for
all the
uncurated dataset then you are likely to
find some pathogenic variants like we
have four pathogenic and likely
pathogenic variants and they can be
listed as uh here so um
this is completely uh
yeah this this
this this type of analysis
can be performed in in in an environment
like r using all the codes that we have
provided here and in addition to
providing this code we also give you a
section where you can try out these
codes in the r console that is loaded in
the back end itself for example here
just by reading what is supposed to be
doing for example
by taking the link
copying the link for the input file and
pasting at the specific position
in the r function
and
this console this challenge or this
technical challenge here is given for
you to test your understanding of the
code that we have given in this specific
section so here you can type complete
the
syntaxes we have left out some of the
portions of the syntax so that you can
get a sense of understanding uh
how these analysis can be performed so
when you complete all the necessary
incomplete syntaxes and you get
success in running the code and
understanding the code in general so
this is just one small example we have
several other examples of these
using these methods and we have specific
assignment where we have given you a
console to try this assignment
for a different
type of data or data that is slightly
different to the type of data that we
have
been
discussing in this specific lesson so
far so that will with that that will
conclude my ah
lecture so uh all of this and and
extensive discussion
and step-by-step uh
processing a step-by-step analysis
building types and everything is
discussed uh
in in a live uh or
asynchronous um
course type in the genomics program and
i hope to see many of you in the program
and we will discuss this and also
several other impactful publications and
example projects with which we can
understand how to perform this analysis
on genomics data to understand the
variance and their relationship to
disease to different pathological state
of the
pathogens and
generally understand the biology of the
sample that we are dealing
so i now
can take some of the questions if you
have any and hand over the podium back
to
sri gauri which has something to say
thank you so please let us know sorry
please let us know if you have any
questions in the chat box and yeah we
will uh discuss them
right sir thank you so much sir
meanwhile the participants are sharing
their queries now i'd like to pass on
the stage to miss pashtar to discuss
about the fee structure and the
associated resources that you get as a
part of the program so over to you spash
thank you so
[Music]
me share my much
so why could you please confirm that i'm
audible and uh if my screen is visible
uh yes the audio is a little bit uh
faded
but otherwise this is it
yes it's all
now the audio is fine
yes it is thank you
perfect perfect
um
so
um
good evening good afternoon or a good
morning from whichever part of from you
all participants are
so i am spurs her and i'm the marketing
manager here at buying biotic so i'll uh
quickly guide you through the fee
structure of the genomic data analysis
mentor guided program and also the
resources
which you will have access to if you
enroll in this program so this is the
program page and
here's the link the program page in the
chat box
you can go
through after the webinar ends
so the program is commencing on 19
september next week from monday onward
so those who are interested to be a part
of this program they can
enroll themselves in this coming week
so when you scroll down you will see the
program overview what exactly we will be
covering the program uh why this program
is designed for whom it is designed and
what all applications or role in genomic
data analysis you will be studying
to
discover the genomic variation or
applied genomics in translational
sciences etc so when you move further
you will see an interactive session
calendar
where there are few dates highlighted
so on
every monday and every friday there will
be a session uh that will be conducted
for this particular program and it can
be either asynchronous session or it can
be either live sessions it will be
uh like we will be
we will um send you a calendar
invitation accordingly
so as you can see here on the right hand
side there are
different sessions which we'll be
conducting on genomics so the first
session uh that is on 19th of uh
september it is on genomic data analysis
where we'll be covering the overview of
the course
where there are different topics related
to next generation sequencing data omics
data molecular determinants of phenotype
then we'll be covering about
applications of bioinformatics
introducing you about the
introduction to bioinformatics
coursework which we have different
terminologies it's healthcare
applications
pharma r d and agriculture etc then
moving on to the second
we will be unraveling genomics and
working with dna sequences using r
then the third is regarding the ngs next
generation sequencing its overview
history and application
so as you will see and you'll scroll
further you will see the title of the
sessions the topics which we'll be
covering and also the online associated
resources which will provide you once
you will enroll for the program
so now moving further uh
scro if you scroll down you will see
three different tenures for which you
can
enroll in this or register for this
particular program
one is 45 days another is 60 days and
then is 90 days
so what is the difference between the
three ten years in 45 days tenure
you will be going through with an
extensive mentor guided training related
to genomics data analysis and the
resources which we include the common
resources which we include in all these
three tenure are
online tutorials project examples coding
sessions session recordings online
mentor support via our skype group or
telegram groups online technical support
and certificate of completion and
example cloud pipelines on t bioinfo
server
so in 45 days tenure as i said earlier
you will be going through with an
extensive mentor guided training program
in 60 days other than
other than the extensive training you
have two opportunities one is one-on-one
mentor guidance like you can
if you have any further query while
going through the training part so you
can fix a one-on-one meet with the
mentor maybe you're 15 to 20 minutes and
get clarify your doubts
secondly you have an opportunity to
draft a research proposal and present it
to mentor for further evaluation and get
expert feedback
and
now moving to the last 10 year that is
90 days
you will be having
the opportunity to draft a research
project
you will be having an opportunity to
draft a research project and
get it published in a good peer-reviewed
journal
so these were the resources which you'll
avail in these 10 years as mentioned and
the difference between these 10 years
now if you will see here on the right
hand side top corner there is a drop
down menu
those people uh they can change
according to their locations the
currency of the program right now it is
in usd
if someone is in nigeria they can go it
for naira if someone is brazil they can
go for brl for euros for
so on
so please accordingly according link
change according to your locations
so this was all about the resources
the
fee structure
of the program and also yes we have
scholarships so those
who want scholarship to get themselves
enrolled for uh for this particular
program they can mail us at marketing at
their omixlogic.com
and uh we'll help and we'll guide you
accordingly
so here's the mail id i'm pasting it in
the chat box
rest uh if anyone is having any queries
related to the registration part or the
resources part uh please
mention it in the chat box and i'll be
here to answer your queries thank you
hello sri gauri
all right thank you yes
yeah yeah okay all right thank you so
much
so if anyone has any queries please put
them in the chat box and i hope to see
you all at the genomic data analysis
program thank you
yes parish has also shared her contact
number in the chat box so if you have
any queries please
share in the
number provided as well
we do have a query uh will the program
involve pac bio analysis and illumina
yeah uh hello most of the data analysis
will actually uh
not consider long read sequencing
analysis or long read long reads um
but the
logic is actually same so we are
focusing mainly on the short reads uh
and that are from the illumina and from
many many other methods which will
produce short read fascio files so
these methods and their
analysis are involved in long waits for
short trees only for the mapping and
identification of the variance but
once you have identified the variance
and using variant calling uh reading
calling informative vcf file the
downstream methods can be applied to the
vcf file that is generated from
basically
any method or any
different
reading right
that part is actually universal but only
the pipeline building of
taking the leads to map it onto the
genome and identifying variants is
specific to the short trade technology
thank you so much sir so
ramadan says thank you sir
all right thank you so much everyone for
your patience if any more queries are
left please put that in the chat or you
can share it in the number provided by
spash thank you so much have a great day
you